i'm already out here a husband still and
this is too much and ain't nobody out
here sticking husbands
nene leakes denies stealing her
boyfriend naomi nisella jco after being
sued by his estranged wife mao lomine
tai mai co for allegedly busting up
their marriage let's just try to show
each other a little more love
on thursday the real housewives of
atlanta star hopped on instagram live to
shut down claims with a little humor
it's a lot going on in the world i'm
already out here a husband still and
this is too much and ain't nobody out
here sticking husbands are they i don't
i wouldn't know there's somebody going
around honey a lot of single people in
the building last night so
um i don't think it's nobody want to
steal nobody else's problems
[Laughter]
nobody steal nobody else probably in the
lawsuit malone mine alleges that nene
and naonicella engaged in an ongoing
romantic uninhibited and adulterous
affair without her knowledge or consent
e.t has reached out to nene's reps for
comment that same day the reality star
posted this video with her boyfriend all
smiles while cruising in the car
listening to a love song money long's
hours and hours
nene has been linked to naomi since last
december when the couple went instagram
official sharing moments from their
tropical getaway but naomi's wife claims
that nene started dating him while he
was still married and court docs
obtained by e.t malomin sued nini for
quote alienation of affection and
criminal conversation
this is nene's first public romance
since her husband greg leaks died from
colon cancer back in september 2021. i
have good days and bad days i'm trying
to adjust to this whole new life that i
have and
my health is normal and despite the
recent husband stealer allegations nene
seems to be happy dating her new man
[Music]